if you are on sky sports mix and you see
this now you already know
so congratulations you cracked the code
and figured it out they cracked the
code to get kenny gallaudet paid almost
a full week into free agency after the
big money in many respects
had flowed to the extent there was any
big money chris this one came
over the weekend on saturday four years
72 million for kenny galladay from the
new york giants it can be
76 million so it's either 18 million
based 19 million
max with incentives per year i had
reported that he was looking for 18 five
some say that's what he turned down from
the lions last year that's
unconfirmed and uncorroborated but i've
heard that from several different people
he wanted 18-5
because he said no to 18-5 in detroit
and of course circumstances changed
between last year and this year with the
pandemic but
gallaudet gets close to what he was
looking for and the giants
get what chris you know i had a gm tell
me last week there are no number one
receivers
in this free agency class is gallaudet
the closest thing to one i think he is i
mean i think that's why
you know one yeah uh he was probably
waiting for that number one type
contract like we talked about a lot over
the last two weeks right
you know somewhere in that 18 to 20
million dollar range
we've seen the receiving you know the
receiver market it's not the same
the market really is not the same for
just about anybody right now except for
maybe a few offensive linemen as far as
years we're used to
but yes i don't think there's any doubt
that he was the number one wide receiver
the crown jewel that's what i've called
him on the
the uh unbuttoned podcast as far as wide
receiver goes
the negativity of course is the one
thing it's it's last year he didn't play
a lot so that's
that scares people yes so between that
and the market
i think he was trying to find the right
place and
i mean i love it as a giant fan i really
do
i'm excited about it i think he is the
type of guy
that jason garrett that new york giants
offense
you know a little bit of the attitude
they're gonna have and now you got
weapons like him he's a big play guy
mike you know he can go over the middle
and do that but man
he can beat you deep over the top like
we've talked about jump balls he's
amazing
in traffic you know i think he is a real
number one wide receiver so i i don't
know who you talk to but i would
disagree i'd say he's a legit one to me
yeah well but is he a guy you're going
to game plan against
is he a guy that you're going to you're
in this that's going to strike fear in
an opposing defense well i'd like to
account for him everywhere
no i hear him everywhere he goes right
yeah is he going to no but i think
you know is he is he that guy like
you're saying you know tyree kills of
the world
the guys that you know oh man we gotta
double them every play no
like not always but i think you're gonna
have to think about it in certain
situations yes
you know depending on your secondary and
things like that but
you know also gonna have to double them
hopefully because they feeding the ball
to such an
extent to where you go wait he's a key
part of their offense we got to do that
so yeah is he the freakiest guy in the
nfl but he goes back into the old
talk talk we talk about there's 15 18
top 10 receivers in the nfl he's among
that group
you know according to who you talk to or
who you you know what kind of receivers
you like and
as far as the giants and trying to make
it work for daniel jones
you know it's a huge year for him it's a
huge year for joe judge i i like the
move all together
he's tied for sixth among all receivers
in contract value per
year and you know the numbers just kind
of blur together for a lot of people
but sometimes you have to take a step
back and say what does 18 million per
year mean what it means is
he's even with tyree kill and odell
beckham jr who got his contract from the
giants a few years ago before it was
traded to the browns
two years ago kind of out of the blue
and stunned us all
but look at the numbers deandre hopkins
still leading the way with 27.25 million
julio jones at 22
a couple of others right at 20. so
there's a gap there
but 18 was the best anyone was going to
do and you mentioned
that for the most part no one was
resetting the market the only guy who
really did reset the market other than
dak prescott who got paid
before free agency and justin simmons
who also
wasn't a free agent signing it was a
second franchise tag
flipped into a market setting contract
for safeties
for the most part you know trent
williams did a
phony deal and it's phony because it's a
three-year deal
that is at a certain level just about 20
million a year and then there's a fake
three years on the back end that will
either get
restructured or ripped up that pushes
him just above david bakhtiari by like
a .1 like a hundred thousand a year
right just so the agent can say i got
the richest offensive line
contract in league history for the most
part you're right markets aren't getting
reset this year no
because the salary cap is 25 million
less than what it would have been but
for the pandemic so
you got to factor that in i think it's a
when you look at it yeah at who's
getting paid
right now now if there was a superstar
on the market
then you know that superstar would get
paid but yeah i say this time and again
these guys are on the market for a
reason chris the lions didn't franchise
tag kenny galladay they didn't want to
pay him 17-9 for one year they let him
walk and he got 18 over four
from the giants yeah certainly and i'm
sure he wanted to go out there and just
see what else was out there anyways i
mean he probably doesn't have the
greatest taste in his mouth from the
time
with the detroit lions it's not like
they've been winning games and it's just
been this dominant football team
so yeah he's going out there on the free
agency market trying to see what's there
to be had
you know and see see what other
organizations are all about i mean hey
listen
you know i look at the giants you know
mike and one thing we talk about you
know i know from time to time when you
talk about like
really good offenses right you got to
have
you know i think three different
elements three different you know
scary things about that offense you know
whether that's back with peyton manning
and
you know is it edgar and james and is it
marvin harrison and it's regulate oh
yeah that's right and dallas clarke oh
man they had that you know you brought
up the greatest show on turf before
you know marshall falk torrey holt isaac
brook oh and
azir akeem who was not a bad fourth
right i just look at the giants and you
go daniel jones year four
you know top ten pick it's been good but
we know it's three
during three sorry it's it's you know
it's
it's
teetering to where we go you know is it
great is it worth the top 10 pick we
don't know but now you at least give him
a chance to really
show what he's about he's a pocket
passer he wants to dice people up with
his right arm
so now you got him with a slayton and
evan ingram who is
inconsistent and barkley coming off
injury but when you look at it from that
standpoint right there
you go whoa those are some names and
some potential for this offense
to to be dangerous and explosive this
year and and i think that's exciting for
giants fans
kyle rudolph joins the mix as well all
right
yeah it's got the potential to be an
interesting offense
and and it removes one more excuse
for daniel jones oh dana jones what do
you expect he doesn't have it he doesn't
have a
a high-end receiver well contractually
now he does and we'll see what kenny
gallaudet can do
that that health question was nagging
a lot of people five games last year 32
catches no 32 targets sorry
32 targets 20 catches 338 yards two
touchdowns
and and
we've talked about this before yeah
sometimes a guy who's in his contract
year
if he doesn't have the financial
security that he believes he deserves
that's right
he won't play through an injury that he
otherwise would have played through it's
the brandon marshall
dynamic that you've explained so well in
the past where you have to be able to go
all in all out all the time and when
you know that an injury can completely
derail your opportunity to get
financial security for yourself and more
importantly for your family
it's it's difficult and and there's
there's been some thought that the
the the gallaudet yes
injury status last year was influenced
to some extent by the fact that he
hadn't gotten paid but the giants are
taking the leap of faith that he's going
to be healthy that whatever it was last
year
if it was contractual or if it was just
some sort of
soft tissue thing that lingered for as
long as it did that that won't be the
issue this year because when you're
making that kind of investment
you want the guy on the field yeah yes
you know
hey listen when you see these type of
like deals getting kenny gallaudet
well he came from the lions he's with
the new york giants oh that's right
a lot of the new york giants coaches you
know we're new england coaches that's
right the detroit lions coaches
matt patricia you know he's back with
new england he came from there obviously
you know i do think there was that rumor
out there during the year that gallaudet
yeah
you know maybe was like you're talking
about
hey i'm not being paid i'm not going to
go put it all on the line right now it
you know at 75
and try to play you know not when you
haven't compensated me fairly and all
those type of things yeah that's part of
the game
no doubt about it but like the first
thing i thought of was that aspect and
they
you know you it could go either way it
could go well the giants talk to you
know the matt patricia some of those
coaches and
oh we don't we don't like that guy you
know it's a little crazy blah blah blah
but they also might know they might not
like him because they felt like he could
play and the injury wasn't that serious
and
and he was protecting himself to how you
just explained so that can also give him
the confidence to go yeah we know the
injury wasn't actually horrible
you know in fact we had some of the
coaches there complaining this past year
that
hey you know we wish he would have
played we thought he could have sucked
it up and played in a few of those
football games
so i mean i i honestly think there's got
to be something there that makes the
giants feel comfortable about gallaudet
either way with some common knowledge
let alone
the player on the football field and i
think that's what's really good
or at least what i think about with that
situation i remember this wasn't one of
those sight unseen telephone deals where
you didn't talk to the player or meet
with the player kenny gallaudet went to
the giants and visited and
at some point joe judge presumably
got in a room with kenny galiden and had
a conversation about exactly what
happened last year
and how much of it was influenced by
the fact that he wasn't getting the
financial compensation that he thought
he deserved from the detroit lions
whatever
it was whatever was said whatever was
done it got the giants comfortable
with the idea of paying him 18 million
per year and
chris this is something that needs to be
said i know it's your favorite team but
i think your favorite team
your favorite team got sandbagged by
somebody because your favorite team's
paying a hell of a lot more than the
next team was going to pay
for kenny gallaudet as best i can tell
the next
and this is this is being charitable
with what i've heard right the next best
offer was max 13 by the bengals
bears reportedly in the neighborhood of
11 or 12 million they were interested
in kenny gallaudet at that price it
reminds me a lot of le'veon bell the
other new york team
yeah that got that that that kind of got
the wool pulled over its eyes a couple
of years ago
the idea that the ravens were all in for
le'veon bell when they
never made an offer and the ravens were
kind of lurking
supposedly with kenny galladay although
i think the reason the ravens were
connected to gallaudet has more to do
with our next topic
but that the giants ended up not
having someone that they were out
bidding by a little bit
they were out bidding someone by a lot
and ultimately may have bidding against
themselves
well i mean maybe i you know i i haven't
i haven't heard enough down that line
yet um
i don't doubt that you know you're
probably right you know that it seems to
happen every year
but i will say again with a guy like
kenny galladay
i mean i don't look at the contract and
think it's crazy
it's what i expected really him to go
into
and and get all along so yeah maybe they
did overpay i guess we'll hear more of
those rumors and that stinks for the new
york giants
but i don't think it's a contract that i
look at and just go oh man it's so
horrible
they're just they've really ruined their
football team how could you pay this guy
you know that in two years it's not
going to look like anything and it's
certainly not but i know it does stink
if that's the case mike and they're
overpaying it
18 million a year who would you rather
have gallaudet or obj
um at all
full hundred percent health i'm going to
take obj
yes but obj is dicey right now like he's
damaged goods
we haven't seen much of obj over the
last three years of football
so i think from that aspect you know
it's scary and
of course gallaudet with his injury last
year but
i don't think it's like yeah obj's more
talented
gallaudet might be a hair more of the
safe investment at this point
okay i'll say that but i don't think the
gap is huge there
i i'll say that too there is
an element of desperation i think in
doing this this doesn't seem like a dave
gettleman kind of a move
to do this and and surely he knows that
people are going to say
why'd you ever trade obj you paid him
the same damn contract or like
and and really i think most people would
agree with you chris that
if both guys are completely healthy
beckham's the better receiver
yeah and and just as obj's coming off of
a torn acl
you've got this this nagging question
with gallaudet playing only five games
in his contract year so
uh hey it's like so many of the other
things we see in free agency it's either
gonna work or it's not well if it
doesn't it's gonna be spectacular
because everybody's going to say why did
you do it why did you do it why did you
do it if it doesn't work for gallaudet
in new york well
yeah they're going to say that but you
know again even with that if they
overpaid and you know the the rumors
that you're talking about end up being
true and everything like that
right it it's a real need for the
football team
like it's a it's a desperate need we saw
the defense turn the corner last year
and we go oh okay they're top 10-ish
defense the way they played
the offense throughout the year we sat
there and went ah
oh man is it hard for them to you know
do anything it was offensive line issues
of course the saquon injury evan ingram
dropping passes
you know the only thing that was really
consistent
is darius sladen and i think that's why
you maybe overpay for a kenny gallaudet
right now
because you go wait our team we feel
like it's in a pretty good place
and this is a position that we really
need
and this is a receiver who you know i
think
like we've like we've discussed was the
number one receiver on the market
so okay the next guy down and the next
guy's down in the conversation
i think there's questions about in
general so i think when you talk about
need for a team supporting your
quarterback who's a top 10 pick
and a big year for your new regime head
coach dave gettleman his butt on the
line and all those type of things
you know i i can get behind it i i
certainly can
and uh i just think you know you haven't
been able to totally depend on evan
ingram
you haven't been able to depend totally
on saquon barkley because of the injury
and you don't know where that's going to
be
they couldn't go into the season this
year and go
well we hope you know ingram's
consistent we hope saquon's a hundred
percent
and we got darius satan you know they
needed something else for sure
and for that i'm not gonna sit here and
go oh my gosh how stupid gettleman is
he paid 17 and a half million dollars
for kenny gallaudet i'm not going to do
it 18. yeah 18 17.
but uh but but you know this is going to
be the ultimate good problem to have if
this all works because then they're
gonna have to pay saquon barkley and
daniel jones if he has some spectacular
josh allen ascension in year three
yeah which we can't rule out the
possibility a lot of people were stunned
last year by what josh allen did if
daniel jones all of a sudden is a
franchise quarterback
then he's going to be on deck for
another contract barkley going into year
four now barkley hasn't been clamoring
for a contract because he's coming off
of a torn acl right but they got some
guys offensively they're gonna have to
pay and golliday's gonna help
yeah it's going to push it one way or
the other either they're going to say
as to barkley and or jones this just
isn't part of the long-term answer for
the franchise or they're going to say
holy crap
we have something that's working very
well and at some level it just could be
a manifestation of john mara's
frustration
that he surely is feeling it's been a
long time since the last super bowl
trophy
for the new york giants a decade now
they've had one playoff appearance in
that decade that is unacceptable
chris as a giants fan you should be as
upset as every other giants fan
one playoff berth right in in ten years
nine years
since or is it ten it's ten years so it
is ten years this year it was 2011
the year they won it you know it's it's
one more super bowl than your team
from that where's purple as one but uh
ever this one i
just wanted to make that clear
[Laughter]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports